hola qué tal estábamos haciendo el
inciso c del primer problema de
respuesta abierta del examen de cálculo
a p voy a volver a leer el problema el
problema decía lo siguiente decía la
región r esta de aquí en la región r es
la base de un sólido aquí le dibuje a la
región r con un poco de perspectiva para
que con un poco de suerte podamos verla
en 3d dice para este sólido cualquier
corte que es perpendicular al eje x hay
varias formas de cortar verdad podríamos
hacer un corte así pero así sería
paralelo al eje x pero lo que queremos
hacer son cortes perpendiculares al eje
x es decir queremos cortar más o menos
como por esta línea como por líneas de
este estilo lo que dice es que cada
corte perpendicular determina un
cuadrado aquí dibuje algunos cuantos
cuadrados aquí tenemos un segmento que
este segmento base y como el corte es un
cuadrado la altura es la misma y sube
perpendicularmente lo mismo por acá
fíjate que aquí en medio los cuadrados
van a ser muy altos porque están muy
lejanas las funciones y finalmente si
avanzamos hacia la izquierda se va
haciendo angosto cómo le hacemos para
encontrar
este sólido es algo difícil de
visualizar pero bueno es más difícil de
dibujar lo es así que pues tienes que
reconocer que me esforcé en mi dibujo
pero va lo que tenemos que hacer
entonces es tomar el área de cada uno de
estos cuadrados y multiplicar la por un
cambio miniatura en x entonces déjame
marcarlo por aquí voy a poner esto en
morado y este cambio miniatura pues ya
hemos hablado de él y le estamos
llamando de x sale entonces si
multiplicamos de x por el área de este
cuadrado lo que hacemos es obtener el
volumen de este corte es como una
rebanada de jamón entonces estamos
encontrando el volumen de esa rebanada
de jamón si sumamos los volúmenes de
todos estos cortes entonces obtendremos
el volumen del sólido como le hacemos
para hacer eso pues tenemos que escribir
una integral entonces vamos a escribir
la integral
cuál es el área de cada uno de estos
cuadrados cada una de el área de cada
uno de estos cortes la base va a ser la
diferencia entre las dos funciones entre
la función superior que habíamos dicho
que es seno de px
y la función inferior y esta función
inferior se llamaba ye ye igual a x al
cubo menos 4x baja entonces la base de
cada uno de estos cuadrados mide lo
mismo que la diferencia de las funciones
y ya sabemos cuáles son las funciones la
función superior es seno
de pie x
- menos la inferior que esta de aquí
menos x al cubo más 4x porque hay que
ponerle un signo más menos x al cubo más
4x hasta aquí esto se parece muchísimo
al inciso a pero cuál es el cambio lo
que tenemos que hacer es encontrar el
área de cada uno de estos cuadrados no
simplemente el lado entonces para
encontrar el área de un cuadrado hay que
elevar su lado al cuadrado entonces aquí
hay que elevar al cuadrado y eso es el
área de cada uno de los cuadrados de
aquí todavía nos falta multiplicar por
el de x por ese cambio miniatura esto
nos da el volumen de cada uno de los
cortes
entonces ahora tenemos que integrar hay
que integrar desde pues hay que integrar
en todo el intervalo verdad entonces el
límite inferior es 0 y el superior es 2
ahora sí ya nada más nos queda encontrar
el valor numérico de esta integral justo
como me pasó en la parte primero intenté
hacer esto analíticamente es decir si
intentar resolver la integral pero
resulta que me quedaba algo super super
super feo que sí se puede hacer
utilizando integración por parte de
varias veces y fórmulas de reducción de
grado pero ese súper tal ayudo
posiblemente si haces eso te tomaría a
todo el tiempo del examen entonces como
el examen nos permite utilizar
calculadoras gráficas creo que ahorita
es un muy buen momento para utilizar la
la calculadora gráfica es súper útil
para encontrar expresiones numéricas de
integrales definidas
voy a sacar por aquí mi emulador de la
calculadora texas instruments
y entonces a ver quiero que veas qué
teclas estoy presionando la aprendemos
borramos la pantalla y lo que vamos a
hacer es el es usar el menú de cálculo
entonces él pongo seco calc y fíjate
aquí me da varias opciones esta que
estoy indicando es para la integral
definida pues le picó efe 5 y entonces
lo que tenemos que escribir es la
expresión ahí va la expresión que
tenemos es la voy a copiar es a ver voy
a ver un paréntesis seno
d
y dónde está y ya tiene mucho que no usó
una de estas aquí está a ver entonces
tengo que picar le shift y equis
seno de px menos x
x
el cubo
+ 4x
y todo eso elevado al cuadrado
y luego le tengo que indicar a esta
función cuál es la variable de
integración es decir con respecto a que
estamos integrando entonces aquí le voy
a poner que nuestra variable es x y
finalmente lo que hay que decirle son
los límites de integración estamos
integrando de 0 a 2
saleh
está todo bien le doy enter mira está
pensando la calculadora a ver qué nos
dice
y aita 9.97 83 esa es la respuesta s de
ahí es el volumen de este solito que
queremos calcular 9.978 3 voy a poner
aquí esto es igual a 9.978 3
a estar listo seguramente tendremos que
utilizar la calculadora porque realmente
calcular esta integral y va a ser súper
intenso y va a ser muy muy tal ayudo y
eso nos iba a tomar muchísimo tiempo
entonces por eso yo creo que las
instrucciones del examen nos dan nos dan
chance de utilizar una calculadora
gráfica lo que hicimos otra vez fue
tomar el área de cada uno de los
cuadrados e integrar todas esas áreas
para encontrar el volumen déjame checar
cuánto tiempo me queda todavía tengo
unos pocos minutos vamos a empezar la
parte de déjame borrar
con él aquí invertir color es parte de
la región r a ver déjame volver a poner
la región r voy a hacerlo un poco más
chiquita sin haber deshacer y volver a
hacer o deshacer pegar ahora sí vamos a
hacerlo un poco más chiquita para tener
un poco más de espacio entonces ahora si
parte de dice lo siguiente la región r
es la superficie de un lago pequeño en
cada uno de los puntos de r que están a
distancia x del eje i
la profundidad del agua está dada por
hdx igual a 3 x entonces esencialmente
lo que nos dicen es que conforme x crece
la profundidad baja en 0 la profundidad
es simplemente 3 porque es 3 - 0 y en
este punto la profundidad es 3 menos dos
que es igual a 1 entonces esencialmente
cada vez se hace menos y menos profundo
el ajo conforme vamos de izquierda a
derecha más o menos podemos imaginarlo
pero déjame intentar hacer un dibujo de
nuevo entonces otra vez vamos a hacer
las cosas en perspectiva esta es la
función seno
esta de acá en la función polinomiales
la función polinomio al cúbica que nos
dan
voy a dibujar mis ejes ese es el eje de
x
luego tengo que dibujar también el eje
de agua es el eje
vamos a ponerle su flechita entonces a
ver ahí va aquí en el punto cero a ver
vamos a ponerlo hdx que es la
profundidad es igual a 3 - x entonces en
este punto la profundidad es 3 entonces
déjame dibujar en azul porque es agua
verdad entonces tenemos que bajar 3
y cada vez se hace menos menos profundo
conforme nos vamos a la derecha entonces
cómo le hacemos para ver cómo le hacemos
para encontrar el volumen de este lago
entonces acá la profundidad es 1 porque
aquí ese es 2 entonces esta distancia 2
entonces a ver vamos a pensar otra vez
en cortes se vería más o menos así un
corte por el eje x vaya sí que está
difícil de visualizar y de dibujar bueno
ahorita ya andamos un poco cortos de
tiempo pero en el próximo vídeo ya vamos
a empezar a pensar en cómo plantearlo y
resolverlo hasta pronto